is this how most of us will live in the
future or is this or maybe this the mass
migration of humans from the country to
the city started with the Industrial
Revolution 2007 according to the UN was
the tipping point when more of humanity
lived in urban than rural areas and the
trend continues a projected 2/3 of the
global population will live in cities by
2050 in the United States cities have
become remarkably expensive because
housing prices have outpaced wage growth
developers don't build enough move
supply to meet rising demand because of
a thicket of regulations that
artificially drive up building costs but
what's not clear is whether the solution
to the urban housing crisis is more
density in the poor or more sprawl in
the periphery or both if we were to
remove the artificial restrictions and
incentives that shape the landscape of
American cities how would our bin'
dwellers choose to live there is a huge
pent-up demand for density and for urban
living that simply is not being able to
get met because of the restrictive
zoning free market policy analysts Scott
buyer who is the founder of the market
urbanism report says that urban
residents want to live close together in
the center city but that local and state
governments are standing in the way
there's things like environmental review
that's often used in a dubious way and
doesn't really address actual
environmental concerns but is used as a
form of obstruction building code laws
that are written by the industry and are
designed to sort of pad the pockets of
certain contractors public review and
developers being forced to have a lot of
community meetings in order to get the
project approved all the different ways
that the government controls the pricing
and use of land the truly affordable
housing would be low density housing
built on the urban fringe libertarian
urban policy analyst Randal O'Toole who
calls himself the anti planner agrees
that many city governments over regulate
land use but disagrees with buyers
assertion that more density is the
answer to housing affordability instead
O'Toole blames so-called Smart Growth
policies meant to increase
urban density by discouraging land
outside of a city proper from being
developed at all a goal furthered by the
passage of California State Senator
Darrell Steinberg 2008 anti green house
emissions law the more we incentivize
and promote development that reduces
vehicle miles traveled the better chance
we will have to meet these very
important and aggressive reduction of
metric tons of carbon the Regional
Council of the Southern California
Association of Governments eight years
ago Southern California's planners
adopted a 23 year regional plan to help
realize steinberg's vision experts
believe this shift in demographics will
lead to less demand for larger Lots and
outlying locations and more demand for
smaller Lots close to shopping the goal
that urban planners have had for many
years is not to make housing more
affordable but to pack people in to
higher density urban areas and that's a
goal that I don't think Americans should
support we used to build an enormous
amount more housing than we do today
when we were a smaller state because we
did it the old-fashioned way
we built enough housing to accommodate
our growth California State Senator from
San Francisco Scott Weiner represents
one of America's least affordable cities
a place where the density question is
hotly debated and hugely consequential
restrictive zoning ensures that housing
is perpetually expensive and out of
reach for most Californians for years
he's been pushing state bill 50 which
would make it easier to build mid-rise
housing near major transit stops by
overriding local zoning rules that only
allow the construction of single-family
homes the legislature voted down the
bill January 2020 for the third time the
opposition includes all of the state
senators from Los Angeles which in
recent years has seen a mild slowing in
the rate of rent increases in the wake
of newly added housing stock I
understand the supply side of housing
production is important we've got to do
it but then I say what about affordable
housing the issue of gentrification
comes up resounding ly in my community
will developers and speculators buy up
the property around me and make my
community look
feel different who will be my new
neighbors Scott Weiner is not going out
in saying let's abolish zoning he's
effectively just saying let's loosen
zoning incrementally so that we can
allow potentially double or triple the
amount of housing on existing land
without really having to add to traffic
that much or change the character of
areas too much LA City Councilman Paul
Koretz disagrees there's so many reasons
to oppose SB 50 that it's almost
difficult to know where to start
Koretz believes a bill like SB 50 would
crowd out low and middle-income
residents even though it would require a
set-aside for subsidized affordable
housing in new buildings with more than
10 units they think that you build the
million luxury units that that will
trickle down and reduce their rents what
we've seen is that that will just
increase rents under the current
circumstance the more luxury housing we
build the more tech companies and others
will attract with well-paid employees
and we're sort of tilting the country
into California III I think it has to be
a balance
I don't think California has a
responsibility to house the entire
country traffic is intolerable we don't
have the infrastructure for it you add a
couple million people to LA when we
become six million people I don't think
it makes it easier I think it makes it
harder for us to do everything Koretz is
also concerned that more apartment
buildings will erode the character of
the city which is predominantly occupied
by single-family homes we would just
ruin the aesthetics of single-family
neighborhoods just because that's Scott
weiners vision so you'd have a
five-story building here and a
five-story building there in the middle
of a single-family neighborhood it would
look like our planners had lost their
minds
modern Los Angeles was born in 1920s as
Americans came to work in the oil fields
in emerging film and aerospace
industries land was plentiful and cheap
and by 1930 94 percent of homes in the
city were single-family but for reasons
that had nothing to do with
single-family zoning rules which hadn't
been widely imposed across the city yet
you FHA assisted projects have cut net
cost about one-fifth be low the cost of
private builders in the same cities
during the New Deal the federal
government started further encouraging
low-density development with the
creation of the Federal Housing
Authority to underwrite mortgages and by
the 1960s homeowners groups were
successfully agitating for more
restrictive zoning rules to protect
single-family home neighborhoods as the
city grew today more than 75 percent of
residential Lots in Los Angeles are
zoned for single-family homes or
duplexes San Francisco followed a
similar trajectory buyer wants Los
Angeles and all American cities to
eliminate these restrictions if you're
actually a working mayor and you're
looking for a politically realistic
thing to do in your city I think it
would be to really question the idea of
whether single-family zoning is
something that should even exist in the
city and then work for ways to ban that
zoning but O'Toole says that growing out
instead of up is the cheaper faster more
realistic path to housing affordability
because both construction and land
acquisition costs are more expensive in
the urban core in a urban area that
doesn't have growth restrictions you can
buy a new house for as little as $100 a
square foot mid-rise housing typically
costs $500 a square foot and high-rise
housing cost six to eight hundred
dollars a square foot so how does that
housing become affordable it becomes
affordable by building tiny units and we
call that affordable housing and that's
what's happening in cities like Seattle
Portland San Francisco and Los Angeles
today despite its reputation for sprawl
California is actually home to seven of
the ten densest urbanized areas in the
country
O'Toole says the effort to fight urban
sprawl his
only driven up the housing costs and
points out that there's still lots of
room for growth on the periphery of
major California cities citing a
state-sponsored report that identified
more than two hundred thousand acres of
privately owned land in both Los Angeles
County and the Bay Area that could be
developed without threatening sensitive
ecosystems or farmland I think that we
should loosen the urban growth
boundaries I'm very much of a pro market
person but if we had an open market I do
not think more sprawl would be the
outcome fire argues that Millennials in
particular want to live in dense
neighborhoods he says that cities like
San Francisco would build taller
buildings in a freer market citing
higher land values as evidence of the
pent up demand fire also points out that
homeowners typically don't pay the full
cost required to get roads electrical
lines and other city infrastructure out
to the suburbs and so I kind of view the
suburbs as an outcome of social
engineering and government planning to a
degree and I look at urban density as
the more organic market-based outcome
but O'Toole says that even with those
costs built in most Americans even
Millennials will prefer living in more
spacious less dense settings
he points to census data showing that
more 25 to 30 year olds are moving from
cities to suburbs than the other way
around and a recent Gallup poll finding
only 17 percent of young people saying
they want to live in a big city urban
planners have spread these myths in
order to justify their goal of
increasing urban densities but that's
not the way Americans have wanted to
live for the last hundred years and
there's no sign that American tastes
have changed
O'Toole atributes the lion ization of
cities - the influence of the urban
theorists Jane Jacobs the object is to
nurture locales where people on foot
will naturally
encounter one another Jacobs landmark
1961 book the death and life of great
American cities blamed the federal
government for destroying city life by
financing the destruction of dense
neighborhoods the truly dynamic American
cities are those that are coming to
grips with the problem of outmoded
structures increasingly we are seeing
large-scale demolition as the first step
in building
modern cities the federal bulldozer
replaced urban communities with
modernists towers in the park that were
missing what Jacobs called the ballet of
urban street life the federal government
also encouraged suburbanization with
federally subsidized mortgages and the
construction of the interstate highway
system
O'Toole agrees with Jacobs critique of
federal housing policy but says that her
idealization of cities led even many
free-market Urbanists to mistake her
particular tastes for the opinions of
most Americans they believe that if we
let the free market work we will end up
with people living in higher densities
and they've never said let's get rid of
the urban growth boundaries let's let
the whole free market work no they only
say let's get rid of single-family
zoning that's not a free market so in a
freer market would we see more density
or more sprawl the city of Houston Texas
provides clues
both byron O'Toole point to Houston as
an American city that gets it more or
less right it's one of America's fastest
growing cities yet housing prices remain
low compared to America's large coastal
cities
what makes Houston unique it's the only
large US city with no zoning whatsoever
and just as importantly two O'Toole no
urban growth boundaries the result a
fairly dense downtown with several
towering skyscrapers but with an
enormous footprint that quickly becomes
far less dense as you move out towards
the periphery if Houston tells us
anything it's that if you liberalize the
market and allow people to move into
your area and access affordable housing
you're gonna get a whole variety of
housing types you'll get everything but
O'Toole points out that Houston's
single-family homeowners can form
so-called protective covenants to
restrict the development of
single-family homes into apartment
buildings he sees this as mostly a
voluntary market phenomenon that
reflects the preferences of homeowners
even though these covenants are
government sanctioned with 75% approval
by homeowners property rights are
sometimes described as a bundle of
sticks
each stick represents a different part
of your property rights one possible
stick in your bundle is a stick that
says I promise not to develop my home to
higher densities provided none of my
neighbors develop their homes to higher
densities either and it turns out this
is a very valuable stick O'Toole says
that if cities were to abandon zoning
they would best serve their residents by
allowing the formation of similar
covenants most single-family
neighborhoods would stay single-family
if somebody has located in a
neighborhood and bought a home in a
hotter bionaire eeeh do they have a
right to deed restrict that area to
prevent other people from moving in I
would say no cities are open labor
markets people need to be able to locate
and live there everyone should have the
right to buy the sort of housing that
they can afford and that is comfortable
for them and I don't think that simply
moving there before the other people did
give somebody the right to then draw off
the gate the density question can only
be answered if the government stops
interfering with the housing market
allowing consumer preferences to shape
the urban landscape and that's something
O'Toole and buyer would both like to see
the government control of land use and
zoning has caused housing to be
unaffordable and I think that market
urbanism is a way to reverse those
trends it's important to distinguish
between affordable housing which is
housing we provide at a subsidy versus
housing affordability they say let's
mandate the developers give usually
fifteen to twenty percent of all new
homes they build at the low cost prices
that's going to make the other eighty to
eighty-five percent of the homes they
build more expensive so many of the
prescriptions they are offering actually
will make housing even less affordable
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]